[Música]
bienvenidos a un capítulo especial de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un magazine informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano en esta oportunidad
les presentamos el segundo nuestros dos
especiales dedicados a la conmemoración
de las 8 independencias que tuvieron
lugar en el continente africano en
agosto de 1960 un año que marcó la
historia del continente especialmente
para los países francófonos de áfrica
occidental uno de ellos es benin en
también en níger burkina faso costa de
marfil chad congo brazzaville república
centroafricana y finalmente gabón en
este capítulo recordaremos las
independencias de los segundos cuatro de
ellos y es que después de benin níger
burkina faso y costa de márfil países
cuyas historias vimos la semana pasada
continuamos hoy hablando de chad este
país proclamó su independencia el 11 de
agosto de 1960 la conmemoración genera
reflexiones en cuanto a esta nación y su
relación en pos colonial con francia se
va a enfrentar en estabilidad económica
a pesar de sus reservas de petróleo
el 11 de agosto de 1960 la capital de
chad aún no se llamaba yamena sino force
lamy y los antiguos colores de la
bandera francesa todavía ondeaban para
luego dar paso al azul dorado y rojo de
la actual tricolor nacional el
presidente del consejo françois tomb al
valle recibe en la capital a
diplomáticos extranjeros y notables de
todo el país
chad es un territorio enorme en la
encrucijada del desierto y el ecuador
los pueblos originarios son numerosos
igual que sus jefes
referí el cacicazgo y el sultanato en su
conjunto en chad tiene su existencia una
estructura tradicional que no debe ser
abolida abruptamente dicho esto e
integrado a los jefes y sultanes en el
desarrollo constructivo de chad no no
estamos de ropa del partido progresiones
comentando al símbolo de la evolución
conflictividad
a partir de 1870 francia quiso competir
con los británicos ya establecidos en el
continente la misión de áfrica central
dirigida por los capitanes vuletich and
one cometió atrocidades contra la
población en 1900 se fundó por lamy la
capital toma su nombre de uno de los
exploradores que murió en el lago chad
veinte años después la colonia se
integró al áfrica ecuatorial francesa
[Música]
en 1940 el gobernador de chad feliz
software fue el primero en ofrecer a
charles de gaulle una porción de tierra
y un ejército para reconquistar la
metrópoli de allí parten las tropas
comandadas por el general leclerc
20 años después el general propone a los
estados que desean la independencia a
formar la comunidad francesa propuesta
aceptada por referéndum en 1962 françois
tomb al valle fue elegido presidente de
la república y abogó por la dge actitud
es decir el regreso a las costumbres
africanas pero su paranoia y
autoritarismo generaron resistencia en
un país con graves problemas económicos
el 13 de abril de 1975 fue asesinado
durante un golpe militar
pues después de benin níger burkina faso
costa de marfil y chad que acabamos de
ver fue el turno de la república
centroafricana que proclamó su
independencia el 13 de agosto de 1960
un país en el corazón de áfrica a
orillas del río ubangui cuando obtuvo la
independencia el 13 de agosto de 1960 la
república centroafricana quiso
desarrollar vías de transporte para
exportar su riqueza representada en
algodón café y recursos minerales fue
david taco de apenas 30 años quien
lideró ese proceso con pocos meses en el
poder
efe
con la república francesa acaba de
reconocer la independencia y la
soberanía internacional de la república
centroafricana y por ello el nombre de
mi país quiero agradecer al gobierno
francés francia ha demostrado así una
vez más a los ojos del mundo que su
misión era la protección de la libertad
durante siglos la esclavitud
transahariana diezmo la población de
áfrica central a finales del siglo 19
los belgas son los primeros europeos en
encontrar el río ubangui pero son los
franceses quienes la convierten en
colonia la van guisar y pronto fue
integrada al áfrica ecuatorial francesa
la colonización fue brutal con trabajo
forzado y saqueo de recursos
[Música]
en los pueblos los hombres serán
detenidos desde los 12 años los ataban
con una soga al cuello y los llevaban
junto a la plantación de algodón donde
trabajaban todo el día sin comer ni
beber algunos morían trabajando y eso me
marcó y propuso visión a ese espectáculo
mamar que en 1946 barthélemy buganda
miembro de la asamblea nacional francesa
creó el movimiento para la evolución
social del áfrica negra el mes sanz se
le considera el padre fundador de la
nación centroafricana pero no asistió a
las celebraciones de la independencia
pues su avión se estrelló el 29 de marzo
de 1959 en extrañas circunstancias
francia impone en el mando a david taco
a expensas de su heredero abel bumba
seis años después fue derrocado en un
golpe de estado que benefició a su primo
y jefe de gabinete jean bédel bokassa el
soldado se proclama emperador de la
república centroafricana él a su vez fue
derrocado por francia en 1979
[Música]
hablamos ahora de la república del congo
también conocida como congo brazzaville
este país independizó de francia el 15
de agosto de 1960 veamos la historia
en 1880 el explorador francés jacques a
reunión de guasa negoció un acuerdo con
los bate que para establecer un
protectorado francés en la orilla norte
del río congo treinta años después el
territorio se convertirá en una colonia
del áfrica ecuatorial francesa donde se
impone el trabajo forzoso y las
condiciones de vida son muy duras en
1928 los trabajadores se levantaron
durante la construcción del ferrocarril
con goteo entre bajas de abril y portbou
según los historiadores este trabajo
costó la vida de al menos 17.000
personas esta historia no es mencionada
por la televisión pública francesa en
1952 cuando se pintó un retrato
ditirámbico de organza que evoca el
desarrollo de la colonia
de la vida divina de la independencia
fue obtenida en 1960 en medio de un
clima de enfrentamientos entre
movimientos políticos de base étnica
el líder silver yulu se convierte en el
primer presidente de la república de
congo a menudo llamada congo brazzaville
por el nombre de su capital el ministro
de asuntos culturales del general de
gaulle 11ma lo representó a francia en
esta ceremonia tres años más tarde
silvia youtube fue derrocado en lo que
fue el primero de una larga serie de
golpes de estado hoy la oposición
congoleña se queja de que el actual
presidente denis sassu nguesso ha estado
gobernando el país de manera casi
ininterrumpida durante más de cuatro
décadas
y es que además de los ocho países que
se independizaron en agosto de 1960
otras nueve naciones consiguieron su
soberanía durante ese mismo año para un
total de diecisiete catorce de ellas ex
colonias francesas sobre ese tema
hablamos previamente con wilfried más
ambas líneas y fotógrafo y también líder
social nació en la república del congo y
radicado en bogotá colombia para él es
importante reflexionar sobre los avances
que se han obtenido durante estos 60
años en el continente con gone in pace
uno que está celebrando 60 años de
independencia sin pompa y con lágrimas y
reconocimientos hace 10 años en víspera
del cincuentenario de la independencia y
me preguntaba que hemos dicho que han
hechos con nuestra independencia hay
fecha con esta fecha que marcan la
historia fecha que nos pasa mar y
cornadas ficha congelada en la memoria
colectiva hay algunas de estas fechas en
la que vale la pena detenerse el 17 de
enero en 1961
patrice lumumba fue asesinado desde
entonces ha entrado en la historia de
áfrica como un héroe como nuestro país
celebró con gran pompa el 15 de agosto
de 2010 el 50 aniversario de su
independencia que debemos recordar que
hemos tenido seis presidentes y tres
guerras civiles que tenemos petróleo
manera y un país magnífico que debemos
preguntar a nuestros padres que han
hechos con sus independencia que balanza
nos dejan juventud desviada en fragrante
falta de infraestructura una insistencia
social explosiva una situación económica
irregular un futuro revuelto que como
como queremos para nuestros hijos para
sus nietos una sociedad justa y
equitativa un país abierto y orgulloso
de su diversidad un país donde todos los
convenios encuentran felicidades y
alegría para vivir allí y después de
escuchar la opinión de wilfried samba
terminamos esta serie de dos programas
especiales de áfrica siete días hablando
las independencias de 1960 con gabón que
conmemora justamente la emancipación de
su país el 17 de agosto de ese mismo año
el 17 de agosto de 1960 el pueblo de
gabón estaba dispuesto a rebelarse y los
ojos estaban puestos en la asamblea
legislativa de libreville
a pesar de su inconformidad ante la
independencia que se le impuso el primer
ministro león mba firmó un tratado con
andré malraux enviado por el general de
gaulle en el siglo 15 los portugueses
desembarcaron en un estuario que según
decían parecía un traje de marinero los
aman gabón o cavan en portugués y pronto
se les unirán los holandeses ingleses y
franceses atraídos por los yacimientos
de oro de madera y por los esclavos
en 1837 el almirante william firmó un
tratado con los reyes en pont ue para
establecer una base permanente 12 años
después un barco de esclavos fue
detenido en la costa los esclavos fueron
liberados y ellos fundaron libreville la
actual capital en 1940 el presidente
francés charles de gaulle fue recibido
por el gobernador del áfrica ecuatorial
francesa félix web el territorio es
finalmente tomado por la francia libre
nombre dado al gobierno en el exilio
francés fundado por de gaulle en ese
mismo año
después de la guerra léon m'ba inició su
ascenso político creó su partido y se
convirtió en el alcalde de libreville
poco apreciado en un principio por los
franceses pero buena estratega logra
suplantar a su rival yang y luego bum
poco después de la independencia
disolvió la asamblea y estableció un
régimen autoritario
al venir el alma somos un pueblo pequeño
necesitamos progreso para elevarnos como
nación creo que la oposición frustra a
nuestros planes debe haber un solo
movimiento
aquí
cuatro años después fue derrocado por el
ejército pero las tropas francesas
intervinieron para devolverlo al poder
para parís no se trata de perder el
control de gabón que ha suministrado
petróleo a francia desde la pérdida de
argelia a su muerte en 1967 fue
reemplazado por uno de sus parientes
aprobado por el eligió al back bernard
bongo
por recordándoles que cada 23 de agosto
se conmemora el día internacional para
recordar a las víctimas de la trata de
africanos esclavizados y su abolición
finalizamos este capítulo especial de
áfrica siete días y los invitamos a
continuar con más información en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom quédense
con nosotros nos vemos más adelante con
más información aquí en france 24
[Música]